NASA says the success of the Artemis 1
Mission means astronauts will be on
board the next flight to the moon the
Orion capsule with no one on board
splashed down in the Pacific Ocean
yesterday near Baja California the
25-day test flight sent home some of the
most amazing Moon images we've ever seen
Mark Strassman has more on NASA's most
ambitious lunar mission in half a
century
Splashdown Orion back on Earth after a
textbook entry bringing its 25 and a
half day mission to an end
its little round trip over but America's
new chapter of deep space voyaging just
beginning I don't think any one of us
could have imagined the mission this
successful and liftoff of Artemis one
last month his dramatic night launch
began the Artemis one test flight in all
a 1.4 million mile space Voyage sitting
in the Commander's seat a mannequin
outfitted with sensors from deep space
Orion beanback spectacular imagery of
the Moon and Earth twice the capsule
flew within 80 miles of the moon's
surface but the mission's biggest test
came during Sunday's return Orion
slammed into the Earth's atmosphere at
25
000 miles per hour the heat shield had
to hold up against temperatures of 5 000
degrees half as hot as the surface of
the Sun we're going to look at the data
very carefully but I would say very
happy with what we've seen so far on the
heat shield Sunday's Splashdown 50 years
to the day after another Landing Apollo
17 touching down on the lunar surface
okay Houston the Challenger has landed
the last time humans moonwalked NASA
wants to return now with the Artemis
program a crude test flight around the
moon in 2024 a moon landing later this
decade it is the beginning of the new
beginning
and that is to explore the heavens
America's new era of moonwalking just
took a giant leap closer for CBS
mornings Mark Strassman Atlanta